hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
sc.l1-3.13.1 monitor control and protect
Communications I.E information
transmitter received by organizational
systems at the external boundaries and
key internal boundaries of
organizational systems
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you we've found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it all right now generally speaking this
control is another one which is
specifically dictating behavior and how
your system must operate in order to be
compliant in case you couldn't figure it
out this control is specifically
pointing out the functionality of a
firewall
who would have guessed protecting
internal and external boundaries is
exactly what a firewall does however I
think it's also important to recognize
that it's not just any firewall will do
there are probably uh you know there are
a lot of assessment points here and the
reality is a router you find at Best Buy
is probably not adequate to do the trick
instead we're going to need a solid
business grade or preferably an
Enterprise grade firewall when we look
at the assessment points I'll show you
why now keep in mind Enterprise grade
does not necessarily mean expensive it's
all about the features it has so again
small micro businesses let me not scare
you you can do this and if you don't
feel comfortable reach out to us and we
can definitely help let's check out what
the assessment points look like on this
one prepare yourself it's a little bit
of a long one I'm gonna sweat really
hard on this teleprompter because this
font is small all right assessment point
one determine if the external system
boundary is defined uh so have we
defined what is on the outside what's on
the inside of our secure network uh if
we were to answer this we'd say hey
Define is those specific authorized
devices which have been authorized and
approved to access cui by the IT team
and the information owner boundary
examples are the individual systems and
access cui and of course the secure
environment right so anything on the
local area network is internal anything
on the wide area network or the internet
is well external so again the external
boundary is the firewall between the
inside secure network and the outside
all right assessment Point number two
determine if key internal system
boundaries are defined so now we're
talking about internal boundaries
uh internal boundaries are defined as
those resources behind organizational
firewalls and behind uh the secure data
Enclave environment so again within
whatever the secure setup is that you
have if you even have one maybe your
entire network is the secure Enclave
assessment Point number three determine
if Communications are monitored at the
external system boundary this is
implemented via the you guessed it the
seam solution if you don't know what a
seam solution is go back and watch some
of our other videos or give us a call
it's the security information and event
management system that you should have
in place to be compliant and of course
firewall monitoring service whether
you're monitoring the firewall yourself
or whether you have an external third
party like us again someone should be
there to be monitoring that next
assessment Point determinative
Communications are monitored at Key
internal boundaries this is implemented
via the same solution and firewall
monitoring service again start breaking
these down a little bit simpler
determine if Communications are
controlled at the external system
boundary implemented via the
organization's firewalls again important
protocol controller great examples of
those
determinive Communications are
controlled at Key internal boundaries
now this could mean a lot of different
things if you're a large organization it
might mean that you actually have things
like sub networks or vlans you know
virtual local area networks could mean a
couple of different things everybody's
going to have a different answer here
but in this example it's not such a huge
Network we're just saying Hey look it's
implemented via the organizational
firewalls that's where it is uh
determine if Communications are
protected at the external system
boundary well are they of course they
are but what it's going to take to do
that is probably to have some kind of a
packet sensing or packet reviewing type
of firewall so again as the packets go
in and out of firewall the key here is
that they are essentially being scanned
for malicious packets or activity and
that's going to be what protects the
external system boundary okay so again
implemented be the organizational
firewalls this is one more reason why a
basic you know firewall without active
packet filtration just really won't work
here uh determinive Communications are
protected at the key internal boundaries
so again implementing the organization's
firewalls your firewall should be able
to do uh you know all of that packet
filtering and packet sensing and you
know hopefully it's you know got some of
those Enterprise grade features like
built-in web filters and malicious
content filters and things like that so
again that's how to that's how to solve
for that so hey and on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day okay even
if you're just struggling to manage the
technology or implement the right
firewall guys we can help on a granular
level just reach out to us we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that is what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance
service roll it out until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]